something about self-esteem doesn't you
mentioned being weak-minded earlier
hearing your crush or people that you
might fancy and realizing that your type
doesn't like you back does that not make
you weak-minded then if self-esteem is
really in self and you're hearing people
you find desirable talk about you in an
undesirable way and you're saying that
made you change even though the change
was for the positive let's say does that
not make you weak of mine because I
think it makes you stay strong because I
made me do something strong I ran a
marathon because I was like you know if
those are the type of guys I want to
date this is what they want and the
difference is women have never heard
what men want but men always change to
try to get us like they try to make more
money they try to get a better safe they
take steroids
they learn how to talk to women and it's
like we have never heard what men want